ubicada en la región Pilbara de Australia Occidental
una cicatriz bella y tenebrosa en la superficie de la Tierra.
Del mineral de oro extraído del mundo,
el 98 % es usado para hacer acero
y es, así pues, un gran componente en la construcción de edificios,
automóviles o electrodomésticos tales como lavaplatos o refrigeradores.
Este es el concentrador solar en Sevilla, España.
Esta instalación tiene 2650 espejos
organizados en círculos concéntricos alrededor de una torre de 140 metros
que se está en el centro.
En la cima de la torre,
hay una cápsula de sal fundida
que se calienta por los rayos de luz que se reflejan hacia arriba
desde los espejos de abajo.
Desde allí, la sal circula a un tanque de depósito bajo tierra,
en donde produce vapor,
que hace girar turbinas
y genera suficiente energía para iluminar 70 000 hogares
pero evita 30 000 toneladas de emisiones de dióxido de carbono cada año.
Esta imagen muestra una deforestación en Santa Cruz, Bolivia
inmediatamente adjunta a un tramo sin tocar del bosque tropical.
La deforestación allí ha sido impulsada primeramente
por la expansión de la agricultura mecanizada
y la cría de ganado,
y mientras el país trata de suplir la demanda de su creciente población,
y alimentarlos,
la destrucción sacrificial de su selva tropical
ha logrado esto.
Se estima que el país ha perdido 1,8 millones de hectáreas de selva
en una década,
del 2000 al 2010.
Este es el distrito Eixample en Barcelona, España.
La imagen global puede ser increíblemente útil,
para ayudarnos a entender cómo funcionan las ciudades,
y cómo podemos planear soluciones más inteligentes de urbanismo,
y esto va a ser cada vez más relevante
ya que se espera que 4 mil 900 millones de personas vivan en ciudades del mundo
para el año 2030.
Esta área en Barcelona se caracteriza por su estricto patrón cuadriculado,
apartamentos con patrios comunales,
y estas intersecciones octagonales,
que permiten que entre más sol, mejor ventilación,
y parqueo adicional a nivel del suelo.
Y aquí vemos el patrón cuadriculado pero bajo circunstancias muy diferentes.
Este es el Campo de Refugiados de Dabaab en el norte de Kenya,
el lugar más grande de este tipo en el mundo.
Para hacer frente a la entrada de refugiados que huyen de Somalia,
en donde hay hambruna y conflicto,
la ONU ha construido esta área de esta manera
llamada la extensión LFO
para albergar más y más refugiados
que están llegando y ocupando estos puntos blancos,
que en realidad son carpas,
que se llenan lentamente con el tiempo.
Si uno tiene alguna de estas imágenes,
tiene un momento en el tiempo.
Si tenemos dos imágenes globales,
podemos contar historias de cambios en el tiempo.
Llamo a esa característica del programa: "Yuxtaponer",
y voy a compartir algunos ejemplos con Uds.
Los campos de tulipanes florecen todos los años en abril en los Países Bajos.
Tomamos una imagen en marzo, unas semanas antes,
y las comparamos con unas tomadas unas semanas después.
Y podemos ver las flores florecer en esta magnificada cascada de color.
Se estima que los holandeses producen 4 mil 300 millones de tulipanes cada año.
En el 2015, dos represas colapsaron,
en una mina de mineral de hierro en el sureste de Brasil,
causando uno de los peores desastres medioambientales
de la historia del país.
Se estima que 62 millones de metros cúbicos de desecho
se liberaron cuando las represas colapsaron,
destruyendo en el proceso numerosas comunidades
incluyendo Bento Rodrigues, que se puede ver aquí antes
y después de la inundación.
Finalmente, 19 personas murieron en este desastre.
Medio millón de personas no tuvieron acceso a agua potable,
por un periodo extendido de tiempo,
y el desperdicio pronto se adentró en el río Doce,
que se extiende por 650 km,
camino hacia el mar,
matando una cantidad inimaginable de flora y fauna a su paso.
Y por último, les cuento una historia relacionada con la crisis en Siria,
un conflicto que ha tomado las vidas de cientos de miles de personas
y desplazado a millones.
Se ve este parche de desierto en Mafraq, Jordania en 2011,
el año en el que el conflicto comenzó,
y cuando la comparamos con una imagen tomada este año, en el 2017,
vemos la construcción del campo de refugiados de los Zaatari.
Así que, como los astronautas del Apolo 8
vieron el amanecer de la Tierra sobre la Luna por primera vez,
no hay manera de que Uds. pudieran imaginar
cómo se verían los lugares que les acabo de mostrar desde el espacio exterior.
Y mientras disfrutan de la estética de la imagen,
una vez entiendan exactamente lo que estás viendo,
pueden entrar en conflicto con el hecho que todavía les guste.
Esa es la tensión que quiero crear con mi trabajo,
porque creo que es esa contemplación,
ese diálogo interno
es el que llevará a un mayor interés hacia nuestro planeta
y una mayor consciencia de lo que le estamos haciendo.
Creo que ver la Tierra desde esta perspectiva
es más importante ahora que nunca.
A través de la increíble tecnología de estas cámaras,
podemos ver, monitorizar y exponer
el impacto sin precedentes que estamos teniendo.
Y no importa si somos científicos,
o ingenieros o políticos
o inversores o artistas,
si podemos adoptar una perspectiva más extensa,
adoptar la verdad de lo que está sucediendo
y contemplar la salud a largo plazo de nuestro planeta,
vamos a crear un mejor
y más seguro e inteligente futuro
para nuestro único e irrepetible hogar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)